Buonasera
la domanda che vorrei farmi con voi
questa sera è che esseri umani saremo in
un futuro pervaso dall'intelligenza
artificiale
È una domanda che spaventa
magari qualcuno ce l'hai già fatta
quando ha visto qualche telegiornale
qualche infografica Che ci racconta dei
numeri del futuro
e ci spaventa per un motivo preciso
perché c'è incertezza
e quando c'è incertezza
perdiamo i nostri punti di riferimento
[Musica]
non sappiamo delle volte più chi siamo o
Chi saremo
quindi Proviamo insieme stasera a
guardare nel futuro con un occhio
diverso non cercando di capire cosa ci
aspetta come se fosse già scritto
ma Proviamo a vedere se possiamo fare
finta
di volerlo scegliere
perché questa è una differenza
gigantesca che è dentro le capacità
umane Cioè la capacità di immaginarsi
diversi e che l'abbiamo persa ed è anche
per questo che ci fa paura quando
guardiamo certe statistiche del futuro
perché una delle cose che ci dicono è
che il cambiamento sarà una velocità
enorme Quindi dovremo continuare a
cambiare e a imparare cose che abbiamo
imparato ad odiare
in tutto il sistema di apprendimento ci
viene detto se facciamo giusto o
sbagliato Non se ci abbiamo pensato e se
ci abbiamo messo del nostro
Se la risposta è diversa da quella che
ci si aspettava Però magari è fuori
dagli schemi è brillante o comunque è
sbagliata ma ha richiesto un lavoro
interiore non viene premiato
generalmente né a scuola è troppo spesso
purtroppo ancora neanche nel mondo del
lavoro
Allora quando guardiamo un futuro che ci
parla
del 50% di noi che da qua dal 2000 che
da qua al 2025 dovrà essere formato da
capo non migliorata qualche competenza
no dovremmo imparare a fare cose che non
sappiamo fare
E allora subentra un male ormai
dilagante che si chiama impotenza presa
cioè noi nella vita possiamo avere
imparato che tanto non siamo capaci
in qualcosa A chi gli va di fortuna lo
ha imparato nel ballo e quindi vecchi se
ne frega nel posto di lavoro se non so
ballare dipende poi che lavoro fai
però molti di noi invece hanno imparato
per esempio riguardo la tecnologia o
riguardo a risolvere problemi complessi
e il mondo invece ci chiederà proprio
questo
altri dati che
ha evidenziato il World economico forum
nel suo rapporto del 2020 ci parlano del
fatto che verranno Cancellati da qua al
2025 85 milioni di posti di lavoro però
buona notizia se ne creeranno 97 milioni
Il problema è che questo
questi 97 milioni nuovi non li sappiamo
fare quindi abbiamo avuto un problema di
formazione e contemporaneamente le
aziende non troveranno le persone
formate
Quindi abbiamo ragione ad avere paura
perché siamo chiamati tutti tutti
a un grosso cambiamento non solo in una
skill in un expertise in una capacità
singola ma proprio una visione di noi
stessi nel come saremo e nel quanto
saremo capaci di adattarci velocemente
tutto questo ripeto ci fa paura perché
non ci siamo abituati non perché non ce
lo abbiamo non ci viene chiesto di fare
qualcosa che l'essere umano non può fare
anzi
l'apprendimento è una capacità innata
dell'essere umano
e che ha avuto la fortuna di stare a
contatto con dei bambini anche per pochi
giorni lo scopre Perché i bimbi non
hanno la zona di comfort non gliene
frega niente si buttano intanto mangiano
qualunque cosa leccano vogliono scoprire
il mondo non gli interessa quello che
sanno già fare Vi racconto una piccola
storiella perché una bimba e la prima
volta che lei stava imparando ad
avvitare una bottiglia quindi a vita
Vitas vita non riuscivano sfuggiva il
tappino Poi a un certo punto Finalmente
ce la fa
era quella faccina no che tutti noi
anche da grandi facciamo quando
finalmente sappiamo fare qualcosa di
nuovo allarghiamo le nostre competenze
Allora riprovo ancora una volta la
seconda volta ci riesce un po' meglio la
terza no la quarta ci lascia un po'
meglio quando vedo che ci riesce un po'
di più in modalità da ingegnere e adulto
mamma nonni zii Venite a vedere cosa sa
fare mia figlia No ovviamente quando
comincia a arrivare la gente che vuole
vedere lei che capacità ha lei lo fa
no
i bambini smettono di fare Non solo
perché sono visti e invece noi sappiamo
fare una cosa e qualcuno ci guarda è un
po' il nostro Ego che è stato maleducato
vuol farsi vedere no i bambini smettono
di fare quello che sanno fare perché
dentro di loro c'è un Gap incredibile da
colmare molto più grande di quello che
dobbiamo colmare noi per essere pronti
per il mercato del futuro
loro da piccolini vedono noi adulti che
camminiamo saltiamo guidiamo la macchina
e non si perdono d'animo un secondo anzi
appena imparano via dammene un'altra
dammene un'altra di sfida questo non per
dire che possiamo tornare piccoli così
in un istante Ma perché ce l'abbiamo
dentro questa cosa Questo è il bello non
ci viene richiesto di fare qualcosa che
non è nell'essere umano Ci viene
richiesto di tornare a goderci l'essere
umano
torniamo ai numeri
la formazione e l'apprendimento continuo
sarà importantissimo ma sempre questo
report del World economic forum ci dice
una cosa davvero interessante e vi
chiedo uno sforzo di immaginazione per
vederla con occhi diversi perché di
solito quando guardiamo queste
statistiche le guardiamo con un buias
cognitivo Cioè siamo sempre lì pronti a
dire quello che non ho manca manca Avete
presente le figurine no ce lo manca e
possiamo sempre sul manca manca
Allora proviamo a guardare quello che ci
chiedono
gli esperti di futuro del mondo del
lavoro del futuro con quest'ottica Ma
siamo sicuri che l'essere umano debba
farsi veramente in quattro per imparare
quelle cose lì Ecco nelle prime 10
competenze necessarie nel mondo del
lavoro Del futuro non ce n'è una tecnica
non c'è programmare in c++ no
ce ne sono 6 su 10 che sono relative al
problem solving cioè alla capacità di
affrontare problemi non ancora risolti
perché per quelli già risolti molte
volte lo faranno gli algoritmi ma
problemi nuovi
con pensiero laterale pensiero
divergente capacità critica ma questo
siamo noi ci siamo evoluti così
le altre sono competenze di empatia di
lavoro in gruppo quindi c'è la capacità
di essere leader la leadership ma anche
la followership c'è anche la capacità di
stare in un gruppo dove c'è qualcuno che
deve guidare il processo e essere
produttivi e propositivi la maggior
parte delle competenze che ci vengono
richieste in futuro rimettono al centro
il Sé Se le leggete in inglese è
incredibile C'è Self Self Self Self
Self Management Self Motivation e così
via
quindi ci picchia se le guardiamo
davvero con la voglia di costruirci un
modello diverso di interpretazione della
realtà e quindi di noi stessi possiamo
dire ma è possibile che ci chiederanno
di essere più partecipanti attivamente a
tutti i processi produttivi è possibile
che forse tante aziende si stanno
accorgendo che in un ambiente
incredibilmente turbolento la struttura
verticale e rigida non ce la farà e
quindi tante stanno provando e se ne
volete un elenco Cioè in un bellissimo
libro che si chiama si intitola
reinventare l'organizzazione di Lalù un
francese che ha è stato il primo
teorizzare questa organizzazione che si
chiamano Till sono potere distribuito
con tanti gruppi che rapidamente
flessibilmente riescono a prendere in
mano le decisioni l’innovazione in
maniera molto più rapida perché ora che
si generano una serie di procedure per
risolvere un problema Il problema Deve
essere già risolto In realtà
Questa sarà la flessibilità
l'innovazione richiesta nel futuro ma
per farlo ci vogliono competenze umane è
chiaro che poi sarà importante essere
anche capace di imparare nuove
tecnologie come usarle come migliorarle
come svilupparle Certo ma lì la meta
capacità che è quella di imparare
rapidamente più importante della
capacità tecnica qui a Biella due anni
fa è venuto lei Charme manager di
Microsoft Italia e in una conferenza Ha
dichiarato che gli ingegneri ne ho
assunti in Microsoft Italia vedono le
loro competenze tecniche obsolete in tre
anni
e non ha fatto un corso di 6 mesi ha
fatto ingegneria informatica dopo tre
anni sono vecchie quindi vuol dire che
dal giorno 1 deve amare imparare
farlo con velocità e anche saper auto
dirigere il proprio processo di
apprendimento perché dall'alto sapere
quello che va imparato rapidamente è
troppo difficile
Ecco questo però come vi dicevo prima un
po' ci mette paura ma vorrei
tranquillizzarvi
ripetendovi che siamo capaci come esseri
umani lo abbiamo solo dimenticato
Allora dobbiamo fare un piccolo ripasso
di come si fa
il Come si fa ad imparare Beh
lo ha Secondo me sintetizzato benissimo
michiel rasnic
professore di ricerca sull'educazione al
MIT di Boston che dice molto semplice
questa parola semplice a me fa sempre
tanto mi affascina No perché le cose
semplici sembrano facili Invece
ovviamente non è mai così le cose
semplici non è detto che siano facili È
solo che sono composti di pochi
di poche variabili pochi passi la prima
cosa per imparare è ed è per questo ve
l'ho chiesto prima saper immaginare
cioè il processo di apprendimento reale
È un processo di apprendimento creativo
e anche questo ci verrà richiesto nelle
aziende e farà la differenza nel mondo
del lavoro del perché scelgono un essere
umano e non un algoritmo perché è
apprendimento creativo dove io mi metto
lì e intanto Immagino immagino cosa per
esempio soluzioni diverse
da quelle già sperimentate
o ha problemi nuovi o anche a problemi
vecchi che rivisito ma dopo aver
immaginato la seconda cosa che bisogna
fare è creare quindi non perdersi lì
solamente nell'immaginazione ma a
cercare di mettere subito nel reale
qualcosa perché con quel qualcosa arriva
al terzo passo che è giocare
l'essere umano come tutti i mammiferi
impara tramite il gioco il gioco cos'è e
con quella cosa che ho fatto la manipolo
la uso La uso anche per usi che non
avevo pensato prima prova usarla al
contrario provo a romperla Cosa fanno i
bambini No Istintivamente Ne provo tutte
quello giocare Dopodiché o certe volte
anche mentre gioco c'è l'altro passo
condividere anche questo è una cosa
tipicamente umana che purtroppo in
sistemi di lavoro che ci hanno abituato
che la professionalità è distacco
l'abbiamo persa non sarà più così la
professionalità sarà connessione non
distacco è per che io vado da un essere
umano perché io ho il rapporto con lui e
mi capisce è per questo che voglio un
team di persone e non stare lì con
cinque algoritmi che risolvono il
problema che ci saranno anche loro ma
con le persone ci starò per la
condivisione che fa parte del processo
di apprendimento creativo la
condivisione mi fa vedere che potevo
giocarci in altri modi potevo
sperimentare altre cose Oppure che le
cose che per me funzionano o per lui non
funzionano Perfetto ora c'è il momento
di riflessione e la riflessione riporta
ancora
all'immaginazione ed è un ciclo che non
si chiude mai e questo è un ciclo nel
quale verremo chiamati costantemente in
causa nel futuro
questo ciclo sarà rivolto a sarà rivolto
a due ordini di attività
e vi chiedo un altro sforzo di
immaginazione per seguirmi in questa
metafora Qualcuno di voi ha mai provato
a fare sport ho imparato a guidare la
macchina spero quando impariamo una cosa
nuova all'inizio c'è un grandissimo
sforzo di consapevolezza di
concentrazione devo stare lì quando
inizialmente impara a guidare la
macchina un attimo che faccio
l'incidente oppure che gratto con la
marcia Anche se oggi sono sempre quelle
automatiche Quindi la nostra
consapevolezza deve essere molto
presente pian piano automatizzo e passo
a parte il cervello sottocoscienza che
lo fanno in automatico come civiltà lo
stiamo facendo con l'intelligenza
artificiale quando un problema l'abbiamo
risolto molte volte hai algoritmo certe
volte quando un meta problema Quindi
anche quando abbiamo affrontato più
volte una serie di problemi riusciamo a
creare degli algoritmi che si inventano
anche soluzioni Ma perché l'abbiamo
fatto più volte
quindi la ripetizione che ci consente di
avere l'esperienza tale per poi creare
automatismi come avviene nel nostro
cervello quando impariamo qualcosa prima
coscienza consapevolezza poi automatismo
Allora se rimaniamo un attimo in questa
metafora cosa faremo in futuro due cose
fondamentali una
innamorarci di problemi nuovi
e da tutti i ragazzi che spero
ascolteranno questo piccolo PC
innamoratevi dei problemi perché la
parola problema deriva dal greco
pro-ballen Che vuol dire lanciare oltre
lanciare avanti uguale a progetto
quindi i problemi sono un modo che ci fa
sono una cosa che ci fa andare oltre le
nostre visioni del mondo questo è quello
che dovremmo fare risolvere problemi
nuovi
un'altra cosa che devo fare un'altra
serie di cose che dovremo fare Sarà
invece riaccendere la consapevolezza e
qui dovremo stare molto attenti a farlo
riaccenderla consapevolezza su problemi
che abbiamo già risolto in passato e che
ormai abbiamo codificato con algoritmi
per vedere ed essere sicuri che quegli
algoritmi ancora rispondono a livello
evolutivo a cui siamo
questo sarà fondamentale continuare a
ripercorrere cose che ormai abbiamo dato
per scontato perché non le facciamo più
e le fa l'intelligenza artificiale
questi saranno compiti per cui noi
saremo sempre premiati Certo ci vuole un
grande cambiamento di prospettiva
bisogna abituarci Al piacere di non
sapere se saremo Capaci perché risolve i
provini Questo invece se ci concepiamo
bravi perché rifacciamo quello che
sapevamo fare ieri e l'altro ieri e
l'altro ieri e l'altro ieri e l'altro
ieri allora no lo farà qualcun altro al
posto nostro
Però è giusto così perché è bello così e
vi dico che è bello così da un punto di
vista neurobiologico perché
l'apprendimento insieme alla
riproduzione
ci dà piacere per un motivo biologico
perché come riprodursi deve scatenare
endorfine per ovvi motivi Altrimenti non
saremo più qua
anche imparare ed espandere le nostre
competenze risolvere problemi che prima
non sapevamo risolvere ci dà un senso di
successo di pienezza e perché Perché
nell'evoluzione Quando l'uomo imparava
qualcosa di nuovo il nostro cervello gli
doveva dire stai bene Sì ancora fallo
ancora fallo ancora Ecco perché siamo
programmati per essere dipendenti dalla
gioia dell'apprendere e che l'abbiamo
visto programmata ma c'è ancora
biologicamente quindi possiamo
riprendercela
Anzi oramai se lo guardiamo da questo
punto di vista dobbiamo ringraziare il
fatto che il futuro ci obbligherà a
riprendercela
perché una cosa che è programmata per
farci stare bene
Certo tutti i cambiamenti mettono paura
lo capisco lo so in prima persona tante
volte mi è successo
e anche qui serve immaginazione
serve immaginarsi diversi e avere la
forza di immaginare come potremo stare
se
quindi è semplice perché ci richiede il
futuro di essere umani e di
metterlessere umano al centro dei
processi più importanti ma non è facile
un ingrediente fondamentale e il
coraggio
il coraggio di essere umani Grazie
[Applauso]